>> You did it again, congratulations, your third machine algorithm decision trees,
you got all the way to the end.
>> We've learned a lot about decision trees.
Let's add some of this new found knowledge to our list of things to
consider when you're picking a classifier.
>> So they're really easy to use and they're beautiful to grow on.
They're, they're graphically, in some sense,
allow you to interpret the data really well, and
you can really understand them much better then say the result of a support vector machine.
But they also have limitations.
>> That's right.
One of the things that's true about decision trees is
they're prone to overfitting.
Especially if you have data that has lots and lots of features and
a complicated decision tree it can overfit the data.
So you have to be careful with the parameter tunes that you're picking when you
use the decision tree to prevent this from happening.
>> Yeah. What comes out could look crazy if your node has,
only did single data point.
You almost always overfit.
So it is really important for you to measure how well you're doing,
then stop the growth of the tree at the appropriate time.
>> One of the things that's also really cool about decision trees,
though, is that you can build bigger classifiers out of
decision trees in something called ensemble methods.
In the next lesson,
we'll give you a chance to actually explore an algorithm completely on your own.
And a couple of the ones that will give you as choices are examples of
ensemble methods.
So if this sounds interesting to you.
Building a classifier out of classifier, then stay tuned in the next lesson.
>> Yeah, you are the super, duper machine liearning researchers on this. So stay tuned.
>> Let's get started.